am Samstag bin ich in ein Restaurant
gegangen gemeinsam mit meinem Verlobten
und wir wollten dort essen und dann
wurde nach meinem Impfausweis gefragt
zum drinnen sitzen dann habe ich gesagt
ja den habe ich auch mit hab ihn vorhin
gezeigt haben sie gesagt ja Sie müssen
auch keine Maske tragen wir haben hier
jetzt 2G 2G bedeutet also es nur noch
genesene und geimpfte in dieses
Restaurant dürfen das selbe ist mir auch
schon vor zwei Wochen im Friseursalon
passiert wo ich meine Haare abblondieren
lassen immer wieder also passiert es mir
dass ich ein Orte bin wo ich nur noch
als geimpfte reinkomme beim Friseursalon
konnte ich nicht nein sagen weil ich
brauchte neue Strähnen das Restaurant
habe ich jedoch verlassen ich möchte
nicht in einer Gesellschaft leben in der
ich nicht gemeinsam auch mit Freunden
von mir hingehen kann die sich
vielleicht nicht wie ich haben impfen
lassen ich möchte nicht in einer
Gesellschaft leben in der es geimpft und
ungeimpft gibt in den ungeimpft ein
anderen Status als ich als geimpfte
haben warum können sie sich nicht testen
lassen und auch in das Restaurant mit
mir gehen ich möchte mehr Solidarität
für die ungeimpften und ich möchte das
ungeimpfte in Deutschland Fragen können
nein ich habe mich noch nicht impfen
lassen ohne soziale ächtungen Kauf
nehmen zu müssen es muss endlich
aufhören dass wir Menschen in zwei
Klassen einteilen das darf nicht sein
und jedem Restaurantbesitzer der das
macht mit den 2gs wird viele Kunden
haben aber mich nicht ich habe mich
entschlossen in der Zukunft Restaurants
zu boykottieren die die zweige-regelung
umsetzen und ich bin geimpft das muss
man ja immer dazu sagen
nach deiner freundlichen Einladung hier
gleich brachial reingrätschen zu müssen
aber ich sehe es glaube ich gleich auf
mehreren Ebenen anders also das eine ist
ja was macht der einzelne Gastronom und
da muss ich sagen habe ich volles
Verständnis dafür wenn jemand sagt ich
wende jetzt diese zwei geregel an
einfach weil es für ihn möglicherweise
eine wirtschaftliche Notwendigkeit sein
kann ja also die alle hatten erhebliche
Einnahmeausfälle in den letzten
anderthalb Jahren und jetzt ist es halt
du kannst mehr Gäste empfangen wenn du
diese zwei geregel anwendest und es ist
natürlich für deine Gäste möglicherweise
auch einfach attraktiver nur es ist halt
eine Auszeichnung für dich die müssen da
nicht mehr die Maske tragen wenn sie
irgendwie von Tisch zu gesehen etc das
finde ich also einfach sehr
nachvollziehbar da trifft glaube ich die
falschen wenn man sagt solche
Restaurants boykottiert man jetzt die
andere Frage ist natürlich politisch
findet man das gut dass überhaupt so
eine Anreizstruktur geschaffen wird für
die einzelnen Gastronomen das zu machen
und da naja sage ich mal kann man so und
so sehen ich persönlich ich glaube dass
das mit dem Anreiz schief gegangen ist
also wahrscheinlich hat der ein oder
andere sich gedacht wir sind Anreiz für
die Gastronomen es ist aber gar kein
Anreiz für die Gastronom sondern ist
eine Bestrafung derer die sozusagen sich
nicht impfen lassen wollen und das ist
mein Problem mit der mit der Regelung
ich habe gar nicht so sehr das konkrete
im Blick das soll jeder selber
entscheiden du boykottierst andere gehen
hin ist ja sowieso eigentlich gut immer
mal wieder daran zu erinnern dass jeder
möglich selber entscheiden können soll
was er macht das können aber ungeimpfte
sozusagen in vielen Lebensbereichen
jetzt nicht mehr und sie werden schief
angeguckt und ich ich glaube dass wir
wenn wir nicht sehr stark aufpassen und
die Regierung hat mit dieser
verordnungs- und Gesetzgebung die
Grundlage schaffen sind wir wirklich so
ein Klima kriegen können dass du
ungeimpfter so eine Art Schimpfwort ist
also dass ich Leute anfangen zu fragen
die neben uns die Nachbarn ich glaube
das sind zwei ungeimpfte oder dass man
sich die Frage stellt kann ich meine
Kinder eigentlich zu dem
Kindergeburtstag schicken die Eltern
sind ungeimpft hatte schon gehört
umgeimpfte Leben wahrscheinlich mit
ungeimpften unter einem Dach das macht
mir wirklich Sorgen weil mich das an
düsterer düstere Zeiten ich glaube das
ist uns als Restaurantbesucher
möglicherweise zukommt nicht durch den
Boykott und die schädlichung der
Gastronomen sozusagen ein Zeichen zu
setzen sondern
laut und deutlich zu akzentuieren dass
die Regierung hier Rahmenbedingungen
geschaffen hat die eine zwei
Klassengesellschaft auslösen
ganz kurz verteidigen ich sehe das
komplett anders ich finde also im
Friseursalon war ich ja schon geschockt
das habe ich ja schon letzte Woche zum
Besten gegeben habe gedacht okay das
heißt langjährige Kunden die diesem
Friseur jetzt über 30 Jahre 20 Jahre die
Treue gehalten haben die empfängt der
Friseur nicht mehr weil man ungeimpft
aber im Restaurant nein nein mache ich
nicht ich konnte heute nur an dem Tag
keine Möglichkeit
nein nein ich suche mir jetzt einen
Friseur wo ich wieder mit Maske sitzen
werde auch wenn ich die Maske hasse wie
du weißt aber ich werde mir jetzt einen
Friseur suchen
ich halte lieber die Solidarität mit den
ungeimpften und werde ins 3G
Friseursalon mit der Maske gehen aber
ich finde dieses im Restaurant das heißt
die ungeimpfen müssen jetzt draußen
bleiben das fand ich wirklich in dem
Moment schockierend und deswegen sage
ich der Gastronom soll Menschen
willkommen heißen aber es ist ja jetzt
diese zwei Klassengesellschaft von der
du sprichst Klaus ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt und mich würde
einmal interessieren wie Wolfgang
Bosbach das auch sieht aber ich glaube
dass wir ja einen super Beispiel haben
wie es auch anders geht das ist das
nördliche Nachbarland von Deutschland
von Schleswig-Holstein das ist Dänemark
in Dänemark gibt es gar keine Regeln
mehr was Gegner angeht und in Dänemark
ist Corona auch nicht mehr die große und
gefährliche Pandemie und natürlich ist
das Virus gefährlich in Dänemark ist
Corona eine gefährliche Krankheit und
das Leben hat sich da doch sehr sehr
stark normalisiert obwohl die impfpfote
in Dänemark jetzt gar nicht so
dramatisch besser ist als in Deutschland
also ich glaube und dass wir auch die
Frage glaube ich an sie ja Bosbach
reagiert die deutsche Politik oder sie
hat auch glaube ich dramatisch
überreagiert Politiker haben generell
ein Interesse Dinge zu regeln für den
Bürger zu regeln weil sie damit immer
dokumentieren müssen ja ich tue ja was
ich mache ja was ein Politiker ist ja
ständig und der Rechtfertigungsdruck und
muss immer wieder auch beweisen dass er
zurecht für irgendetwas gewählt wurde
dieses 2G zeigt ja eigentlich wieder nur
dass etwas geregelt wird was Bürger
möglicherweise gar nicht mehr brauchen
als Regel die den machen es uns vor oder
liege ich mit der thesepolitiker müssen
alles regeln falsch jedenfalls Stall die
These denn ich muss die zeitliche
Abfolge sehen Friseur kann ich nicht so
sagen ich habe noch nie die Haar
einbauen lassen alles vom lieben Gott
alles Natur Restaurant ist die private
Entscheidung des Gastronomen und wenn
sie mal die DEHOGA Fragen ein buntes
Bild die einen sind dafür die anderen
sind dagegen das ist die private
Entscheidung nicht richtig so wie es
andere wäre ich mal vorsichtig so wie es
ihre Entscheidung auch ist ob sie das
Angebot jetzt annehmen oder nicht oder
ob sie sage ich das verstanden als
geimpfte solidarisch sind mit mit den
ungeimpft genau das was natürlich hohe
Wellen schlägt ist der Fußball mein
Verein 1 fC Köln da geht es ja um 10.000
hat sich für 2G entschieden es gab
Kritik aber weit überwiegend Zustimmung
ob das durchgehalten werden kann ist
eine andere Frage wir haben ja auch wenn
noch einen langsamen im Fortschritt ist
auch die Frage wie lange wird es noch
dabei bleiben
wir haben am Anfang die Bilder aus
Bergamo gehabt wo sich die Särge
gestapelt haben wir haben die Bilder aus
New York gehabt ist doch klar dass die
Politik dann gesagt hat Gürtel und
Hosenträger
die First Oberziel war immer keine
Überlastung unseres Gesundheitssystems
keine Triage und wir haben das
eigentlich
besser gemeistert als die meisten
anderen Staaten um uns herum aber jetzt
sind wir in einem Stadium wo man sagen
kann andere machen doch vor dass es
gehen warum stehen wir noch auf der
Bremse aber das ist ja glaube ich
entscheidend bei dem was du auch sagst
also man kann immer in die Vergangenheit
schauen beim Thema Bergamo ist auch
nicht ganz klar wie diese dramatischen
Teilzahlungen gekommen sind das muss man
auch mal sagen Thesen sind hätte es
jetzt in diesen Tagen keine
Bundestagswahl gegeben wer schon vor
vier Wochen der Freedom Day gekommen
glaube ich glaube das ist glaube schon
falsch zu sagen aber machen am 31
Oktober Frieden day ohne zu wissen wie
dann die Lage ist normalerweise machst
diese gute dieser gute sozusagen gut
bürgerliche Grundsatz Vorsicht ist die
Mutter der Porzellankiste heißt es
glaube ich nee
der war sozusagen besonders ausgeprägt
wegen dieses wahldatums keiner wollte
mit einem Vorstoß oder mit der
Verantwortungsübernahme kurz vor der
Wahl in die Situation kommen
tote irgendwie verantworten zu müssen
selbst wenn sie gar nicht existieren
sondern nur möglicherweise kommen können
und ich glaube dass diese dieses Wald
Datum hat uns sozusagen in den Herbst
gebracht und jetzt in einem gemutmaßte
neue Welle von der ich auch länger
nichts mehr gehört habe also die
irgendwie nicht so richtige Ausmaße
erreicht und ich glaube dass jetzt das
in diesen koalitionsverhandlungs und so
die immer noch nicht sozusagen den den
Punkt gibt zu sagen wir lösen jetzt mal
die Bremse ich habe im Moment eine
andere Sorge will ich auch in einem
Punkt entgegenkommen wenn der Staat
etwas anbietet geht's gar nicht mit zwei
Geber öffentlichen Einrichtungen ich
habe die die wirklich politischen
gesellschaftliche ich denke dass wir
mittlerweile den Ausnahmezustand zur
Regel erklären und derjenige der von
seinen Grund und Bürgerrechten
gebrauchen haben muss der ist jetzt
nachweispflichtig ob das verantwortlich
wir haben ganz stimmrechtlich umgedreht
genau
die Sorge durchaus auch generell so ein
bisschen was das zerfallen der
Gesellschaft angeht in geimpfte und
ungeimpfte und die Vorbehalte die es da
so gibt aber gleichzeitig muss man nicht
ich bin ja wirklich eigentlich ein sehr
Freiheit ich denke der Mensch aber
dieses sehr starke solidaritätsbedürfnis
dass du formuliert hast Nina das habe
ich zumindest nicht in dem Ausmaß weil
ich schon denke wir haben ja nur meinen
einen möglichen Lebensbereichen ständig
Freiheitseinschränkung ist doch immer
eine Frage von Kosten und Nutzen und in
diesem Fall scheint mir einfach die
Kosten also sich impfen zu lassen sind
wirklich nicht besonders hoch außer man
treibt sie immer genervt in die Höhe
weil man sich irgendwie einredet die
Impfung sei mit Mikrochips durchsetzt
oder sonst irgendwelchen schwach sind
und der Nutzen ist schon beträchtlich ja
okay Dänemark zeigt dass es zumindest
momentan offenbar auch ohne geht und in
dem Fall würde ich sagen machen wir es
gerne wie Dänemark aber trotzdem es ist
so ein Thema also so richtig
leidenschaftlich kann ich da nicht
werden bei der Verteidigung des Rechts
sich nicht impfen zu lassen
[Musik]